wir schauen auf die nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt und da geht es um
Anträge zur Änderung der
Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen sind dort
des Deutschen Bundestages
und da geht es insbesondere um die
regierungsbefragung die an jedem
Mittwoch stattfindet die dynamische und
interaktiver gestaltet werden soll nach
dem Willen der Ampel Fraktion hier im
Deutschen Bundestag bislang hat es sehr
strenge Vorgaben zu Dauer und
Reihenfolge der Fraktionen gegeben das
soll aufgelockert werden und außerdem
soll die regierungsbefragung von bisher
60 auf 90 Minuten verlängert werden und
so sagt es zumindest die Ampel sollen
zukünftig mindestens zwei
bundesministerinnen und oder
Bundesminister teilnehmen um Fragen von
aktuellem Interesse zu beantworten das
könnte tatsächlich spannend werden und
schauen wir mal wie die Ampel das ganze
begründet erster Redner dazu ist
Johannes Fechner aus der SPD-Fraktion
Herausforderungen und wir haben oft hier
im Bundestag gerade in diesen Wochen
sehr komplizierte Gesetzesvorhaben und
Sachverhalte zu beraten und gerade in
diesen schwierigen Zeiten ist es aber
wichtig dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
unserer Entscheidungsabläufe und unserer
Entscheidungen nachvollziehen können
dass sie sie erleben können und deswegen
ist es gut dass wir mit dieser Änderung
der Geschäftsordnung für mehr
Transparenz sorgen hier im Bundestag das
schafft Vertrauen und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir heute diese Änderungen
beschließen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir schaffen mehr Öffentlichkeit und
Transparenz und das tun wir zum Beispiel
indem wir mehr Öffentlichkeit zulassen
in der Ausschussarbeit ich freue mich
sehr dass im Januar mindestens sechs
Ausschüsse beschließen werden dass sie
grundsätzlich öffentlich tagen und
ausdrücklich regeln wir darüber hinaus
dass öffentliche Sitzungen soweit ist
technisch die Übertragungskapazitäten
hier ermöglichen gestreamt werden und
alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger sich dann
diese Sitzungen der Ausschüsse anschauen
können damit haben sie viel einfacher
zudem auch noch die Möglichkeit sich zu
informieren das gilt auch für die
Regelung dass die Protokolle zukünftig
schneller einsehbar sind bei den
öffentlichen Sitzungen werden Sie
unverzüglich veröffentlicht und bei den
nicht öffentlichen Sitzungen spätestens
nach einem Jahr mehr Transparenz
schaffen wir auch bei den
Sachverständigen Anhörungen
Sachverständigen müssen zukünftig
angeben in den Anhörungen ob sie mit dem
Regelungsgegenstand ein persönliches
Interesse verbindet das ist wichtig
damit wir genau wissen Vertreter jemand
eigene Interessen oder die Interessen
von Dritten wenn er fachauskünfte gibt
oder möchte er hier tatsächlich das
Gesetzgebungsverfahren beeinflussen oder
ist er wirklich neutral das sind ganz
wichtige Hinweise und deswegen ist auch
gut dass wir das in der Geschäftsordnung
hier Regeln liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die vorliegen wir
Geschäftsordnung die stammt ja im
Wesentlichen aus dem Jahr 1980 und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir hier
für dieses Update sorgen und dabei
insbesondere auch die Chancen der
Digitalisierung nutzen und dazu gehört
eine Regelung jetzt als dauerregelung zu
normieren nämlich während der coronazeit
da hatten wir geregelt das
Ausschusssitzungen online stattfinden
können das hat sich bewährt und deswegen
werden wir das jetzt als dauerregelung
in die Geschäftsordnung übernehmen das
macht uns flexibel und insbesondere in
nicht Sitzungswochen müssen da nicht
wenn es erforderlich ist zu einem für
eine Sitzung zusammenzukommen die
Abgeordnete nicht aus der ganzen
Augenblick nach Berlin reisen das ist
nebenbei auch klimafreundlich liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und wir beraten
ich habe zum Thema Digitalisierung ein
paar Takte gesagt in dem Zusammenhang
will ich auch darauf hinweisen dass die
i undk-kommission heute eine
Machbarkeitsstudie in Auftrag gegeben
hat und wir wollen bis Ende Februar
nächsten Jahres vorgelegt bekommen wie
wir hier mit welcher Variante genau
welchen Varianten zu welchen Kosten
elektronisch abstimmen können bei den
namentlichen abstimmen ich finde das
sollten wir tun denn etwa im
Europaparlament oder auch im ein oder
anderen Landtag da gibt es schon sehr
lange diese Möglichkeit wir wollen uns
anschauen was ist die beste Lösung
machen wir am Platz fest installierte
Geräte machen wir es mit aus gegebenen
Geräten oder mit dem eigenen Tablet
darüber werden wir dann beraten und dann
natürlich auch in dem Zusammenhang die
Fragen die sich dann weiter für die
Geschäftsordnung ergeben ich finde das
macht Sinn denken Sie nur an die
Abstimmungen zur Impfpflicht da saß mir
fast den ganzen Vormittag hier und
mussten warten das ist nicht
bürgerfreundlich das kann schneller
gehen lassen Sie uns also diese
digitalen Chancen auch unseren
Parlamentsbetrieb nutzen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und schließlich
schaffen wir auch Klarheit ob
Bundesbedienstete insbesondere der
Bundesrechnungshof an öffentlichen
Anhörungen teilnehmen können der
bundesrechtungshof ist eine wichtige
Einrichtung wir sind immer dankbar für
die klugen Hinweise die wir von dort
bekommen und deswegen ist es gut dass
wir jetzt hier eine klare Regelung
getroffen haben im Änderungsantrag
zukünftig kann auf Beschluss des
Ausschusses geregelt sein dass
unabhängige Bundesbedienstete wie etwa
der Bundesrechnungshof an öffentlichen
Anhörungen teilnehmen können und ich
darf auch darauf hinweisen dass wir dem
besonderen der besonderen Bedeutung des
Datenschutzes Rechnung tragen die der
Datenschutz für uns hat nämlich das auch
der
Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte immer dann
wenn ein Gesetzesentwurf ganz erheblich
mit Datenschutz zu tun hat
an der Sachverständigen Anhörung
teilnehmen kann das ist eine ganz
wichtige Klarstellung und zeigt wie
wichtig uns der Datenschutz ist liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und auch ganz
wichtig wir werden die
regierungsbefragung lebendiger gestalten
und dazu gehört dass wir zunächst einmal
die regierungsbefragung um 30 Minuten
verlängern und vor allem das ist die
entscheidende Neuerung das zukünftig
zwei Regierungsmitglieder
Kabinettsmitglieder gleichzeitig in
einer regierungsbefragung anwesend sein
werden das ermöglicht dann nach ich
nenne es mal ein Kreuzverhör die
Gegenüberstellung von verschiedenen
Positionen also ich glaube das wird ein
ganz spannendes Element werden wenn hier
zwei Minister zur Ministerin zur
Verfügung stehen und das ermöglicht auch
dass wir sie viel länger befragen sie
werden nämlich doppelt so oft wie bisher
da stehen das heißt unter dem Strich äh
stehen hier dem Parlament uns
Abgeordneten für unsere kritischen
Fragen häufiger die Ministerinnen und
Minister zu Verfügung auch das ist eine
ganz wichtige Maßnahme weil wir so
Politik erlebbarer spannender machen und
die Bürger viel mehr für unsere Arbeit
hier interessieren können liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich komme
zum Schluss darf nicht bei allen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch der
Opposition für die Zusammenarbeit
bedanken auch der Bundestagsverwaltung
ein herzliches Dankeschön für viele
wichtige Hinweise das hier ist das erste
Paket wir haben uns auch schon
vorgenommen dass zweite Paket zu
schnüren da werden wir gleich im Januar
loslegen da werden wir uns damit
beschäftigen insbesondere wie wir die
Arbeit hier familienfreundlicher
gestalten können lassen Sie uns heute
dieses erste Paket für mehr Transparenz
und für mehr Vertrauen der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in unsere politische Arbeit
beschließen vielen Dank
Johannes Fechner war rechtspolitischer
Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion in der vorigen
Wahlperiode ist jetzt einer der
Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer das
gilt auch für Patrick Schnieder der als
nächster Reben wird aus der
Unionsfraktion die Wahl
schließen oder gibt es noch jemand der
seine Stimme noch nicht abgegeben hat es
rennt niemand los das ist gut dann
schließe ich hier mit die Wahlen und
bitte um da gab es ja eine ganze Reihe
was hier gewählt worden ist bin ich mal
gespannt ob wir das hier in den nächsten
Dreiviertelstunde die wir etwas mehr die
wir noch haben die Ergebnisse noch
reinbekommen beispielsweise zu Wahl eine
Stellvertreter also der Präsidentin
Patrick nieder ist ja nicht so Redner
aus der Unionsfraktion da ist der
parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer und
der Bundestag diskutiert über Änderungen
an der Geschäftsordnung eine
Verlängerung beispielsweise der
regierungsbefragung über Online
auszusitzung öffent Ausschusssitzung und
elektronische Abstimmung und manches
mehrvision unterziehen auf die Höhe der
Zeit bringen
Debatten lebendiger zu gestalten dem
Parlament gerecht werden dass sich
weiter aufgefächert hat mit
verschiedenen Fraktionen
familienfreundlicher werden an die
Digitalisierung anpassen gemessen an
diesem Anspruch an der Notwendigkeit die
wir alle sehen ist das was wir heute
vorgelegt bekommen
allenfalls ein Reförmchen
immerhin ein Reform wenn das der
Anspruch der Ampel ist dann sei euch das
gegönnt immerhin haben die Vorschläge
die wir eingebracht haben ja dazu
geführt dass man sich genötigt zieht und
das ist ja vollkommen richtig in einem
zweiten Paket das dann auch umfassender
und professioneller anzugehen als dass
das vorliegt denn das was sie hier
aufgeschrieben haben erschöpft sich ja
im Wesentlichen neben all den
Ankündigungen die gemacht worden sind in
zwei Punkten das eine ist eine
Veränderung der
regierungsbefragung von 60 auf 90
Minuten statt einem Ministerin eine
Minister dann zwei Ministerin oder
Minister und die Öffentlichkeit von
Ausschusssitzung
und wenn wir die regierungsbefragung und
die Vorschläge uns anschauen da muss man
sagen das ist ja eine Mogelpackung
denn sie erweitern von 60 auf 90 Minuten
erweitern auf zwei zu befragende wenn
ich das mal auf die Zeiten zurückrechnen
haben wir nur noch 45 Minuten pro
Minister also ein Rückschritt und ich
lasse es nicht gelten dass man sagt im
Umlauf passiert das immer öfter es wird
lebendiger und es wird der
Kontrollfunktion der Abgeordneten und
insbesondere der
Opposition dann gerecht wenn ich mich
konzentriert auf ein Thema auch einmal
kaprizieren kann je weiter ich das auf
welche ich kann auch zehn Minister in
drei Stunden nehmen dann kommen die noch
öfter daran aber es zerfleddert
natürlich eine Diskussion und das
scheint ja gerade zu gewollt zu sein es
ist ja das kann man verstehen und es
wird ja dadurch untermauert dass die
Regierung jetzt auch die Reihenfolge
kurzfristig festlegen kann bzw festlegen
kann wer sich denn der
regierungsbefragung stellen muss wir
haben auch im Moment keinen idealen
Zustand dass eine feste Liste besteht
die dann abgearbeitet wird aber im
Moment passiert dann mal dass sich der
befragen hier stellen muss der auch
gerade im Kreuzfeuer steht der
öffentlichen Kritik dessen Themen gerade
die Bevölkerung und auch das Parlament
polarisieren das macht lebendigen
Parlamentarismus aus auch wenn die
Regierung jetzt einfach sagen kann wir
schicken nächste Woche dann mal zwei ins
Feld die nicht so im Mittelpunkt stehen
dann schwächt auch das die
Kontrollfunktion des Parlaments der
Parlamentarier und der Opposition und
ich habe den Eindruck dass geradezu das
eben gewollt ist
und dann wende ich mich der
Öffentlichkeit von Ausschusssitzungen zu
das was die in einem ersten Schritt hier
machen ist soll er in der Tat nur ein
erster Schritt sein gewollt ist ja das
im Wesentlichen die Ausschüsse insgesamt
öffentlich tagen sollen es entsteht ja
auch Druck das hat die Anhörung ergeben
es entsteht ja auch Druck dass ich
Ausschüsse öffnen
öffentlich zu Tagen weil andere das eben
auch machen wir haben Bedenken dass das
wirklich zu mehr Transparenz führt denn
es besteht ein Bedarf daran dass man
sich eben auch einmal ungeschützt äußern
unterhalten muss dass man ohne jedes
Wort abzuwägen miteinander redet
vielleicht auch mal das ein oder andere
aushandelt ohne in der Öffentlichkeit
sofort so zu stehen das gilt übrigens
für Regierung wie Opposition man ist
eingeknickt man hatten Vorschlag eines
anderen übernommen und die Folge wird
sein auch darauf haben die Experten
hingewiesen das können Sie beobachten im
Europäischen Parlament können Sie
beobachten im Landtagen die das zur Hand
haben dass die geschützten Räume eben
vorverlagert dann werden sie andere
Runden haben in denen diesen Bedürfnis
Rechnung getragen wird und deshalb sagen
wir das sollten wir uns in der Tat noch
einmal überlegen wir wollen attraktive
Debatten transparente Debatten hier im
Parlament im Plenum haben und wir haben
doch heute schon das Problem dass wir
mit den wenigsten Debatten wirklich im
Fokus der Öffentlichkeit stehen die
schalten lieber die Talkshow am Abend
ein und wenn wir das hier noch einmal
konzentriert
als Debatte als Herzkammer der
Demokratie auch darstellen wollen dann
gelingt das sicherlich nicht indem wir
immer mehr öffentliche Formate hier
etablieren in denen letztlich dann auch
nur Schaufenster Reden gehalten werden
wir warnen davor dass so zu machen das
kann im Einzelfall sehr sinnvoll und
nützlich sein aber als allgemeines
Instrument da stimme ich den Experten zu
die das in der Anhörung so auch da
gebracht haben wollen wir das nicht
ein Lob für dich aussprechen das
betrifft die Möglichkeit ohne auf eine
Mehrheit angewiesen zu sein der
Bundesrechnungshof an als anhörerperson
demnächst zu benennen
die Worte habe ich gerade wohl gehört
aber die Tatsache war doch das Ihnen die
Kritik des Bundesrechnungshofes am
sogenannten Bürgergeld nicht gepasst hat
und deshalb das abgebügelt worden bis
heute liegt es im
Geschäftsordnungsausschuss die
auslegungsentscheidung ob die ob der
Bundesrechnungshof anhört Person ist
oder nicht wir haben das geklärt sie
haben Sie unseren Argumenten hier
gebeugt deshalb bin ich froh dass wir
das in Zukunft hier dann ordentlich
geregelt haben meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
ich bin mal gespannt auf sich
tatsächlich die Kraft haben werden in
einem zweiten Paket die Dinge anzugehen
die wir wirklich angehen müssen von
Digitalisierung ist ja bisher überhaupt
noch nichts zu spüren wir haben den
Vorschlag gemacht sie können das in
unserem Antrag alles lesen
Familienfreundlichkeit zu erhöhen
vielleicht auch im Zusammenhang mit
Digitalisierung mit der Bündelung da wo
es geht von Abstimmungen mit
elektronischen namentlichen Abstimmung
wir müssen die Geschäftsordnung von
einer Menge Totholz mal beseitigen es
gibt eine Menge von Dingen die wir noch
zu regeln haben bisher haben gefunden
bin gespannt ob ihnen das gelingt wir
sind jedenfalls dabei wir bringen uns
gerne ein auch konstruktiv ein das war
ja jetzt
kaum möglich her Kollege weil bei der
ersten Lesung die fand in der Nacht
statt und das ob Leute Gespräch am
Vormittag das gleiche Tags dann kann man
nicht erwarten dass man hier in der
breiten Art und Weise konstruktiv ein
solchen Gesetzentwurf oder einen solchen
Antrag unterstützen kann wenn das
vernünftig läuft sind wir gerne mit
dabei
patricchen Lieder aus der Unionsfraktion
einer der Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer mit Kritik an der
geplanten Reform der regierungsbefragung
mit zwei Ministerinnen da muss man ja
sagen ob diese Form attraktiv wird hängt
ja auch ein klein wenig davon ab wie die
Qualität und Intensität der Fragen ist
vieles Polat Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführerin Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Abgeordnete in diesem Haus und ähm in
unserem Koalitionsvertrag vor Jahren nun
einem Jahr haben wir uns vorgenommen
dass das Parlament als Ort der Debatte
und der Gesetzgebung gestärkt wird und
das genau das bringen wir jetzt auf den
Weg Herrn nieder und wir werden das
haben die Kollegen gesagt gleich ähm am
mittwochs mittwochs loslegen mittwochs
mittags wenn wir üblicherweise die
Sitzungswochen beginnen mit der
Befragung der Bundesregierung und die
Regierungsmitglieder freuen sich schon
richtig darauf
an dieser regierungsbefragung nun mit
zwei Minister in teilzunehmen denn es
ist schon in der Vergangenheit einiges
passiert bei der regierungsbefragung
aber da war noch Luft nach oben und Rede
und Antwort stehen demnächst zwei
Ministerinnen in der regierungsbefragung
und damit dagebinden sind wir uns sehr
sicher wird die
regierungsbefragung lebendiger
dynamischer und flexibler und es werden
tagesaktuelle Themen vertieft und der
Kollege Schnieder es geht doch weniger
darum die regierungsbefragung in die
Länge zu ziehen die im übrigen länger
wird sondern es geht darum wie sie als
Opposition oder wie wir insgesamt als
Parlament diese Befragung letztendlich
auch lebendiger gestalten also es liegt
in unserer Hand als Abgeordnete
für eine lebendige regierungsbefragung
auch unser unseren Beitrag zu leisten
wir werfen mit der Reform Licht in die
Maschinenräume unserer
parlamentarischenden Arbeit Herr Schmid
und ich weiß nicht wovor sie Angst haben
bisher sind wir doch auch sehr
transparent in Debatten des Deutschen
Bundestages so viel anders ist das in
den Ausschüssen tatsächlich auch nicht
auch dort geht es mal heiß her auch dort
wird intensiv beraten genauso wie er
hier im Bundestag ich denke sie brauchen
keine Angst zu haben wenn die
Öffentlichkeit wenn die Ausschüsse sich
für die Öffentlichkeit entscheiden der
Grundsatz der Ausschüsse dass sie nicht
öffentlich tagen entfällt wir als
Bündnis 90 die Grünen sagen endlich
Gesetzesarbeit wird damit
nachvollziehbar
und ganz ehrlich in Zeiten da die
BürgerInnen zunehmend Zweifel an unserem
demokratischen System zum Ausdruck
bringen halten wir es auch für ungemein
wichtig ein weites gehenden Einblick zu
geben wie Entscheidungen zustande kommen
wie wir Abgeordnete beraten tatsächlich
auch das kann spannend sein und
Bürgerinnen werden demnächst dann auch
live mitbekommen weil diese öffentlichen
Ausschusssitzungen werden gestreamt
werden mitbekommen wie dieses sogenannte
struktische Gesetz funktioniert dass
eine Vorlage eben wie sie in das
Parlament hereinkommt oder auch
herauskommt eben ganz anders ist meine
Damen und Herren in zehn Bundesländern
Tagen die Ausschüsse das hat der Kollege
Schnieder gesagt bereits jetzt
grundsätzlich öffentlich und auch im
Europa-Parlament sind die Ausschüsse
öffentlich und vor zwei Wochen hatten
wir eine sehr spannende Anhörung die
Kollegin die das noch mal nachverfolgen
wollen oder auch die BürgerInnen die
waren die Anhörungen sind nämlich bei
uns öffentlich da einer von den
Sachverständigen zu dieser Reform
tatsächlich gesagt vom Professor
Bernhard Wegener von der Uni Nürnberg
erlangen dass das nicht nur ein Gewinn
sein kann sondern eben auch ein
wichtiges Element der Repräsentation
meine Damen und Herren ja genau das ist
es und es ist gut dass wir jetzt diese
ersten wichtigen Schritte gehen die
nächste Reform steht schon vor der Tür
wir werden aber jetzt für mehr
Öffentlichkeit sorgen wir gehen aber
auch neue Wege es wurde gesagt wir haben
die Pandemie hinter uns und in Zeiten
der Pandemie sind wir wie viele auch
digitaler geworden und die Präsenz haben
wir insofern für die elektrische Form
auch in Ausschussberatungen ermöglicht
diese Regel wollen wir beibehalten
allerdings nur in Ausnahmefällen so dass
dann auch zukünftig Ausschüsse in
digitaler oder in hybrider Form Tagen
können meine Damen und Herren das ist
sicherlich nicht ein Reförmchen sondern
eine sehr wichtige größere Form für uns
die die
[Musik]
das ist vielleicht eine Frage der
Perspektive und die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger werden
natürlich auch dann ihr Urteil bilden
wenn sie an den öffentlichen
Ausschusssitzungen auch tatsächlich
teilnehmen für uns war es wichtig Herr
Schnieder das haben wir ja sehr deutlich
gesagt die Geschäftsordnung ist
vielleicht für viele was technisches
aber sie ist wirklich das Grundgerüst
mit dem wir hier gemeinsam agieren und
als demokratische Fraktion was uns
eigentlich wichtig dass wir hier alle
gemeinsam diese Geschäftsordnung
verabschieden verabschieden und deswegen
sind wir ja auch auf Anträge ihrer
Fraktion die sehr spät vorgelegt wurden
deswegen auch die späte gemeinsame
Beratung eingegangen und haben auch
Punkte aus ihrem Antrag übernommen sie
haben es ja selber gesagt und im übrigen
auch Anregungen der Fraktion Die Linke
und es werden gutes Signal gewesen auch
mit dem Angebot weitere Punkte
aufzunehmen dass sie am Ende zustimmen
wollen sie haben aber vom Anfang an
deutlich gemacht dass sie dieser Reform
nicht zustimmen werden das ist die
Wahrheit das ist schade in Zeiten wo die
Rechten dieses Parlament am liebsten
auslösen wollen die Geschäftsordnung ist
unsere Basis auflösen wollen ja sie
fühlen sich angesprochen Herr Brandner
interessant das ist wirklich interessant
ich komme zum Schluss unser Ziel bleibt
es den Rahmen zu schaffen für eine
lebendige transparente Ausgestaltung
unserer täglichen Arbeit eine Etappe
haben wir jetzt geschafft liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich lade Sie
alle ein gemeinsam mit uns mit Ausnahme
des der ganz rechten hier im Hause mit
uns die Arbeit im Bundestag unsere
Demokratie noch spannender erlebbarer
und sichtbarer zu machen vielen Dank an
die Kolleginnen für die guten Beratung
ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
vieles Polat war das Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführerin der Fraktion Bündnis
90 der Grünen in einer Debatte über
endo-anträge zu Änderungen der
Geschäftsordnung im Bundestag nicht nur
der Ampelkoalition sondern es liegen
hier auch Anträge 4 der Linksfraktion
vor und drei aus der AFD dazu unter
anderem dazu jetzt mutmaßlich Stefan
Brandner
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
nach den Heuchler innen jetzt der wahre
Demokrat in diesem Haus meine Damen
dieser Deutschen Bundestag ist die
Herzkammer unserer Demokratie hier wird
über das Wohl und wir inzwischen von
über 84 Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland entschieden man sollte
meinen nach demokratischen transparenten
und rechtsstaatlichen Verfahren dem ist
aber nicht so denn sie alle außer der
AFD brechen hier tatsächlich jeden Tag
das Recht seit über fünf Jahren an jedem
plenartag brechen sie das Recht die ganz
große Koalition der angeblichen
qualitätsdemokraten Versuch hat Angst
vor der AFD Opposition hat Angst vor der
Wahrheit sie arbeiten täglich daran uns
auszugrenzen um den Bürgern draußen
vorzuenthalten was tatsächlich hier was
in unserem Land vorgeht sie ignorieren
den Willen von Millionen Wählern die die
AFD gewählt haben sie verweigern die
Alternative für Deutschland die ganze
Zeit über fünf Jahren den
Vizepräsidenten Posten geregelten
paragraph 2 Absatz 1 der
Geschäftsordnung sie treten das mit
Füßen sie verwehren uns seit über einem
Jahr die drei Ausschussvorsitzenden die
drei stellvertretenden
Ausschussvorsitzenden geregelt in
paragraph 58 der Geschäftsordnung sie
treten es mit Füßen stattdessen haben
sie jetzt eingeführt ich glaube auf Idee
des Kollegen kubiki die faktischen
Ausschussvorsitzenden die in der
Geschäftsordnung gar nicht geregelt sind
dass sie scheren sich ein direkt darum
was in der Geschäftsordnung geregelt ist
und erfinden Dinge Geschäftsordnung gar
nicht drin sind bevor wir uns also drin
stehen bevor wir uns also über Reformen
der Geschäftsordnung unterhalten liebe
Freunde von den qualitätsdemokraten
setzen Sie doch einfach erstmal die
fortschriften der Geschäftsordnung um
die umstreitig sind nicht mal dazu sind
sie in der Lage gleichwohl verschließen
wir uns
verschließen wir uns guten Gedanken mich
und haben auch gute Gedanken eingebracht
die Präsenz im Plenum auch heute wieder
mäßig woran liegt das ganze es Tagen
parallel Ausschüsse und Gremien Tagen
parallel zu diesem Plenum wir sagen nein
es soll keiner Parallelveranstaltung
geben hier findet die
plenar-veranstaltung statt und nirgendwo
anders ja das ging ja alles gar nicht es
wäre ein arbeitsparlament der Deutschen
Bundestag womit sie dann irgendwie
suggerieren andere Parlamente wären
würde keine arbeitsparlamente und das
ist ein Hybris die wir Ihnen auch nicht
durchgehen lassen wir von der
Alternative für Deutschland wir wollen
ein arbeitsparlament deshalb fordern wir
wie eine tibitanische Gebetsmühle seit
fünf Jahren mehr Sitzungswochen immer
wieder scheitert das Ganze an ihrer
Bequemlichkeit sie haben sich bei ihren
2021 Sitzungswochen von 53
Kalenderwochen eingerichtet in diesem
Jahr im nächsten Jahr haben wir als
Alternative für Deutschland einen
kleinen Erfolg erzielt nach langem
Ringen und kämpfen der AFD ist endlich
soweit
22 Sitzungswochen im Jahr 2023 dafür
zunächst mal vielen Dank Alternative für
Deutschland wirkt auch ihr wenn auch nur
in kleinen Schritten jetzt bin ich ja
gute Hoffnung der Flächen als
angesprochen dass die Ausschusssitzungen
jetzt wer oder weniger digital
stattfinden können das kann ja dazu
führen das kann er dazu führen dass sie
unserem Antrag jetzt zustimmen und sagen
stimmt wenn wir schon digitale
Ausschusssitzungen außerhalb von
Sitzungswochen stattfinden lassen können
da brauchen wir nicht mehr parallel zum
Plenum stattfinden das genau der Ansatz
den wir auch verfolgen also steht
eigentlich der Zustimmung ihrer Fraktion
zu unserem Antrag nichts im Wege meine
Damen und Herren wir wollen auch das
Gestotter dieses künstliche Gestotter in
diesem Parlament abstellen ein
Paradebeispiel war ja gerade Frau Polat
von den Grünen alle Umfragen der letzten
Jahre zeigen uns dass Gendern wird in
Deutschland abgelehnt von einer von
einem erheblichen Teil von einem
Großteil der Bevölkerung und sie
gewähren sich hier die sprachgesteuerte
die so tun als müssten oberen
BürgerInnen und Meisterinnen in den in
den Sprachgebrauch einkehren wir reden
interessanterweise von
Außenminister innen also mit anderen
Worten die Sprache wird von ihnen
verhunzt das aber weder wog noch schick
noch regenbogenartig das ist schlicht
nur blöd deshalb unser Antrag auf die
gendersprache in diesem Parlament zu
verzichten damit bin ich am Ende meiner
Rede wünsche Ihnen gleichwohl eine
besinnliche restliche Advents und
Weihnachtszeit vielen Dank
lieber Herr Brandner sie haben ihre
Vorrednerin indirekt als Heuchlerin
bezeichnet
dafür erteile ich Ihnen entsprechend
unsere Geschäftsordnung einen
Ordnungsruf
[Applaus]
und der nächste Redner in der Debatte
ist Stefan Thomy für die FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren von allen Verfassungsorganen der
Bundes Deutschland ist der Bundestag das
einzig direkt vom Volk gewählt man
vergisst es so leicht im Alltagsgeschäft
aber wir vertreten hier das Volk und ich
finde das ist auch in der Agentur des
Gebäudes sehr gut zum Ausdruck kommt wir
sitzen als Vertreter hier unten im
Plenarsaal über uns in der Kuppel die
sogenannten Besucher des Bundestages die
hier eigentlich aus der Mitte des Volkes
sind über uns sagt sich immer so leicht
und klingt vielleicht auch ein bisschen
wie eine Phrase aber wir dienen diesem
Land das vergisst man gern aber sollte
immer dran denken und deswegen müssen
wir auch den Menschen besser erklären
wie unsere Arbeit und unsere Arbeit
Weise vonstatten geht und darum bemühen
wir uns in einem Teil des heutigen
Handwerks den wir in als Koalition
vorliegen meine Damen und Herren denn
denn wir wollen einen tieferen Blick in
den kleinen Maschinenraum der Demokratie
in den Motorraum des Parlaments erlauben
und das ist die
echtzeitübertragung aussehen weil es
einen Teil damit wollen wir beginnen der
Ausschüsse des Deutschen Bundestages die
Menschen sehen ja immer nur in den
Fernsehnachrichten dieses dieses Plenum
und denken das das ist doch der der
Bundestag und sehen dann naja manchmal
sind es auch gar nicht so gut gefüllte
Reihen und man denkt sich wo sind denn
die Abgeordneten sind nicht bei der
Arbeit aber das ist ja nicht unser
einziger Arbeitsplatz sondern die Arbeit
des Abgeordneten findet auch in einer
ganzen Reihe anderer Formate und eben
auch Räumlichkeiten statt in den
Ausschüssen in
berichterstattergesprächen in
öffentlichen Anhörungen in
Presseterminen in Expertengesprächen in
Kommissionen Arbeitskreisen
parlamentariergruppen und anderen mehr
und ein Teil davon wollen wir wir jetzt
besser sichtbar und erlebbar machen denn
die Menschen müssen verstehen müssen
besser verstehen können auch sehen
können und ein Stück weit miterleben
können was wir tun denn das schafft
Vertrauen und auf dieser trauen sind wir
angewiesen und deswegen wollen wir die
aufschlussarbeit besser verstehbar und
erlebbar machen meine Damen und Herren
nun haben wir erlebt der Kollege
Schnider ja dass da Ängste bestehen ob
nicht ausschusskultur verloren geht das
ja das das Diskutieren auch mal ins
Unreine hinein einen Argument
ausprobieren ist blau hineinsprechen
aber wenn wir ehrlich sind naja dann ist
sind Ausschüsse auch nicht ein Ort der
vertraulichen diskreten geheimen beraten
sind keine vertraulichen runden dafür
sind auch viel zu viele Leute da aber
sie sind auch mehr als nur ein Mini
Plenum sie sind sie sind fachlicher
vertiefen einzige Gesichtspunkte Stärke
als es im Plenum möglich wäre sind aber
wirklich auch weniger als ein
wissenschaftlicher Kongress dafür gibt
es einfach zu viele Themen und zu wenig
Zeit aber sie zeigen schon viel
deutlicher wie Gesetze entstehen wie
Argumente auch abgewogen werden wie
Expertenbefragung der Ergebnisse
abgewogen werden und deswegen ist es
schon ein eine Möglichkeit besser
darzustellen wie das Parlament arbeitet
und deswegen finde ich es ja schade und
eigentlich auch nicht gerecht diese
diesen Reformschritt also Reförmchen
abzutun und auch ein bisschen zu
diffamieren die echtzeitübertragung wird
schon ein tiefen Blick hineingewähren in
die Arbeitsweise des Parlamentes bin mir
auch sicher dass die Ausschüsse die als
erste beschließen werden dass sie ihre
Sitzungen Echtzeit übertragen ein
Bedeutungsgewinn erleben werden es wird
sicherlich nicht weniger Erkenntnisse
geben ich selber habe mir selbst auch
schon beobachtet dass ich mich in
Sitzung die öffentliche übertragen
werden überhaupt nicht anders verhalte
als in Sitzung die nicht übertragen
werden und deswegen glaube ich auch
keine schlechten Diskussion geben
sondern eher bessere meine Damen und
Herren
ich bleibe im zweiten Punkt heraus das
Thema regierungsbefragungen eigentlich
ist ja die regierungsbefragungen sehr
sehr interaktives Element eine viel
interaktiver als die Debatten hier sind
wo oft mit vorbereiten reden denn
vorgetragen wird und deswegen wollen wir
dieses Element auch sterben sie haben es
gesagt von 60 auf 90 Minuten verlängern
statt einem Minister zwei Minister oder
Ministerinnen und das ist meines
Erachten sowohl eine Aufwertung des
Parlaments wie auch der Minister und nun
gab es einen interessanten Gastbeitrag
des Kollegen Thorsten frei von der Union
vor einer guten Woche die Kanzler
Befragungen häufiger zu machen und zwar
eine Art primemester Question Time wie
im britischen Unterhausen einführen habe
ich glaube dass die Dramaturgie des
Bundestages eine andere ist wir haben ja
Kanzler Befragungen aber schon die
räumliche Anordnung des Plenums
aussehender Pult ist eben eine andere
als das gegenüberstehen im
westministersystem wo sich
Opposition und Regierung auf engem Raum
gegenüber sitzen von daher glaube ich
das auch das Ressortprinzip das bei uns
ja gilt 25 Grundgesetz deutlich macht
die Minister führen schon ihre source in
eigener Verantwortung und die wollen wir
hervorgehen und das bringt unser Antrag
wie ich meine deutliche heraus und
deswegen ist das eine echte
Modernisierung ein erster Schritt weiter
werden folgen und auf die Beratung dazu
freue ich mich schon sehr vielen Dank
für die Fraktion DIE LINKE hat das Wort
dr Petra
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ich habe mich 2015 das letzte mal
intensiver mit der Geschäftsordnung
befasst jetzt bin ich in folgender
Krankheitsvertretung in die Gespräche
gekommen aber ehrlich gesagt hat war
nicht schwer reinzukommen weil sich seit
2015 faktisch nicht verändert hat
insofern das Murmeltier war wieder
unterwegs und es ist auch wirklich so
unsere Geschäftsordnung ist jetzt nicht
gerade eine idealfassung nein vielmehr
haben gerade die Kollegen der Union also
das muss ich Ihnen ja jetzt mal wirklich
auf die Stille schmieren
viel Ehrgeiz daran gesetzt auf der Hand
liegende Änderungen auszusitzen also da
muss ich ihn ausdrücklich widersprechen
auch Öffentlichkeit der
Ausschusssitzungen auch
bis Zuordnung braucht selbstverständlich
Demokratie ein Update und in Zeiten
vielfältiger krisenunsicherheiten muss
es doch gerade zu inniges Bedürfnis eine
jeden Abgeordneten und jedes
Abgeordneten sein komplexe
Entscheidungen nachvollziehbar zu machen
und damit
steht und fällt natürlich auch
Unterstützung außerhalb des Haushaltes
nicht nur passiv ertragen was wir hier
beschließen sondern eben auch mitwirkend
beeinflussend und dazu können eben auch
öffentliche Ausschusssitzung beitragen
das war also das zentrale Anliegen
meiner Fraktion bei den Diskussionen um
die Geschäftsordnung bisher war das ja
so der Kollege hat gesagt grundsätzlich
Tagen die Ausschüsse nicht öffentlich
stand wie in Stein gemeißelt wir haben
dann immer Anträge gestellt die sind
regelmäßig abgelehnt worden hat also bis
auf die Anhörungen nichts öffentlich
stattgefunden jetzt geht die Koalition
in halben Schritt weiter das
grundsätzliche entfällt aber trotzdem
ist die Ausschusssitzung immer noch
nicht öffentlich wir müssen nämlich
trotzdem im Ausschuss entscheiden ob die
Ausschüsse Sitzung öffentlich oder nicht
öffentlich stattfinden soll und dann
haben sie Beipackzettel dazugelegt sie
haben ein paar Hinweise gegeben woran
wir alles denken sollten wenn wir die
Ausschüsse Sitzung tatsächlich
öffentlich machen das liest sich also
dann schon ein bisschen so als ob die
Bedenkenträger aufgefordert werden
verhindert das und vor allem dann wenn
es kontrovers wird wenn die Themen
tatsächlich auch in der Öffentlichkeit
kontrovers diskutiert werden da könnte
ich mir vorstellen dass der eine oder
andere sagt wissen wir uns ja jetzt hier
nicht antun wir Tagen nicht öffentlich
ich sage wir sagen das grundsätzlich
passt in die Öffentlichkeit der Satz
muss heißen die Ausschüsse tagen
grundsätzlich öffentlich und Punkt
zu Fragestunden die sollen jetzt auf 45
Minuten verkürzt werden das ist
problematisch und zwar deshalb weil
nämlich dann nur noch öffentlich direkt
zugänglich ein Teil der Fragen wird
einige Fallen völlig weg einige Bereiche
man bekommt praktisch nur die
schriftliche Antwort die bekommen aber
nicht die Leute die zugucken insofern
ist das also schon ein bisschen
schwierig die verlängerte
regierungsbefragung Verlängerung ist
okay zwei Minister ist Minimum absolutes
Minimum und wenn Sie schon verlängern
dann könnten sie ja eigentlich auch
sagen dass die ganzen
Regierungsmitglieder die also ohne guten
Grund entschuldigt sind hier rede und
antwortstellen stehen könnten immerhin
profitiert von den Änderungen derzeit
vor allem die Regierung weniger das Haus
in dem nämlich auch noch die Regierung
acht Minuten jeweils reden darf nicht
mehr nur fünf und sie darf die Themen
setzen also meine lieben Kollegen das
ist eine Selbstbeschränkung dieses
Parlaments wir sind hier die Herren und
Frauen im Hause also wie auch immer
überlegt es gibt eine ganze Reihe
bestverbesserung in der Geschäftsordnung
und deshalb werden wir uns enthalten
Petra Sitte ist bei diesem Thema zwar
eingesprungen was die Betreuung und
Begleitung angeht hat aber ganz
offensichtlich Spaß daran gefunden wie
man diesen Beitrag hier noch entnehmen
konnte jedenfalls er hat sie den 100
anderen detaillierten Punkt hier noch
mal gemacht janieren ist der vorletzte
Redner in dieser Aussprache und der
kommt aus der SPD-Fraktion
heute Abgeordnete in den demokratischen
Fraktionen als im Juni dieses Jahres
hier einige corona-regelnde
Geschäftsordnung verlängert haben haben
wir bereits angekündigt dass wir diese
diese Geschäftsordnung grundsätzlicher
überarbeiten wollen genau das tun wir
jetzt und haben ihn dazu einen Antrag
mit einigen Vorschlägen vorgelegt wir
wollen die Ausschussarbeit transparenter
gestalten das heißt die während der
corona-pandemie bereits eingeführten
Regeln digitaler Ausschusssitzung zu
ermöglichen wollen wir verstetigen weil
wir gelernt haben wie dieses Mittel
unsere parlamentarische Arbeit hier
vereinfachen kann und wir wollen es den
Ausschuss in ermöglichen öffentlich zu
tragen worum geht's uns dabei ein
Großteil der politischen Arbeit hier im
Bundestag findet nicht im Plenum statt
sondern in jeder Sitzungswoche arbeiten
und debattieren wir in den Ausschüssen
in den Fraktionen in den Arbeitsgruppen
und in vielen verschiedenen Treffen und
Sitzungen hier im Plenum an diesem Pult
in den Reden kommen die Ergebnisse
dieser Diskussion an und ist natürlich
richtig dass das vor den Abgeordneten
vor ihnen vor den ZuschauerInnen auf den
Tribünen Fernsehen und im Internet
passiert dass diese Debatten hier
ankommen
denn die Gesetze die wir hier
beschließen aber auch die ganze
politische Arbeit die da drin steckt
sind Rees publica eine Sache der
Öffentlichkeit und als Sache der
Öffentlichkeit gehören sie vor die Augen
der Öffentlichkeit Politik und
Parlamentarismus sind ja nicht selbst
Zweck sondern finden ihren Zweck darin
allgemeinverbindliche Regeln für unser
Zusammenleben aufzustellen das Prinzip
der Demokratie will dass das im Auftrag
von und in Verantwortung gegenüber den
Menschen in unserer Gesellschaft
passiert es ist deshalb gut wenn diese
Menschen darauf vertrauen können dass
das in ihrem Sinne geschieht es ist
besser wenn Sie das mit ihren eigenen
Augen kontrollieren können deshalb ist
es gut wenn nicht nur das Ergebnis
unserer Arbeit sondern auch unsere
Arbeit selbst öffentlich wird deshalb
ist es gut wenn wir die Ausschussarbeit
jetzt öffnen und damit mehr
parlamentarische Arbeit vor die Augen
der Öffentlichkeit bringen
mit zwei weiteren Maßnahmen wollen wir
für mehr Klarheit und Transparenz sorgen
soll zum einen möglich sein dass auch
die ausschussprotokolle öffentlich
einsehbar sind und wir wollen künftig
bei Gesetzesänderungen eine Synapse
voranstellen damit man schnell sehen
kann welcher was der aktuelle Stand und
was Änderungen am Gesetz sind außerdem
wollen wir die regierungsbefragung etwas
beleben das haben wir schon gehört das
ist alles hilfreich
um die Parlamentsarbeit
selbstverständlicher zu machen es hilft
aber auch um die Arbeit einzelner
Abgeordneter und einzelner Fraktion
verständlicher zu machen warum ich das
erwähne wir haben zu unserem Antrag noch
einige weitere vorgelegt bekommen in
denen sich auch gute Vorschläge finden
mit denen wir uns im weiteren Verfahren
noch beschäftigen wollen und Herr
Schneider ich freue mich über das
Interesse dass da offenbar jetzt auch in
ihrer Fraktion so groß ist ich wünschte
mir dass es hier noch ein bisschen
stärker vertreten wäre es gibt also
diese viele gute Vorschläge mit denen
wir uns beschäftigen werden und dann
gibt es noch einen Antrag der AFD die
AFD gibt damit vor und das haben wir
jetzt gerade auch noch mal gehört an der
Arbeitsfähigkeit dieses Parlamentes oder
an Demokratie interessiert zu sein ist
natürlich Quatsch und das bekommen wir
hier jede Sitzungswoche mit das
Gegenteil ist der Fall in den
Ausschüssen und hier im Plenum behindern
und zermürben die Abgeordneten der AFD
die Arbeit dieses Parlamentes und der
Vorschlag mehr Sitzungswochen
einzuführen zeigt sehr gut wie die
Abgeordneten da ihre Arbeit verstehen
ich wie viele meiner Kolleginnen sind in
den nicht Sitzungswochen im Wahlkreis
unterwegs und arbeiten da offenbar tun
die Abgeordneten das sagt der AFD das
nicht und
gerade in diesen Tagen ist mir das noch
mal wichtig darauf hinzuweisen während
nämlich draußen reichsbürgerin
rechtsextreme und Nazis Waffen sammeln
und Pläne schmieden um diese
parlamentarische Demokratie zu stürzen
sitzen sie hier drinnen um dieselbe
Demokratie von innen zu zersetzen
und der parlamentarische Arm dieses
Rechtsextremismus der parlamentarische
Arm des Rechts Terrorismus der sitzt da
vorne das ist die AFD
liebe Kolleginnen
wir diskutieren ja ja beschweren sie
sich es ist so wir diskutieren liebe
Kolleginnen auch gerne weiter darüber
wie wir mit Änderungen an der
Geschäftsordnung des Bundestages die
parlamentarische Arbeit hier verbessern
und zu mehr Klarheit darüber beitragen
können was hier passiert
fürs erste
Ordnung fürs erste für erste bitte ich
aber liebe Kolleginnen und Zustimmung zu
unseren Vorschlägen und freue mich auf
die weitere Diskussion mit Ihnen vielen
Dank
yandiren für die SPD-Fraktion ist ja im
Ausschuss für Wahlprüfung Immunität und
Geschäftsordnung und um diese
Geschäftsordnung des Bundestages geht es
hier ja auch wir sind beim letzten
Redner angekommen
jetzt hören wir mal auf und hier
gegenseitig jetzt hier noch super rufe
zu zu äh
werfen denn äh wenn dann gibt es hier
Möglichkeiten Kurzintervention zu machen
es gibt Möglichkeiten das der
Fragestellung wenn Rednerin und Redner
reden wir alle besprechen ja gerade die
Geschäftsordnung hier
und von daher bitte ich auch dass man
bei zurufen auf persönliche
Beleidigungen verzichtet
und ich lasse mir das Protokoll
der Rede von Herrn Dirren noch mal geben
und entscheide dann ob es einen
Ordnungsruf gibt oder nicht
und jetzt hat der letzte Redner in der
Debatte das Wort der Kollege der
Unionsfraktion Michael Friese
frau Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen also brauche mich jetzt mit der
Vorrede nicht besonders Aufhalten des
mit diesem echten Kritik an der
Demokratie von innen irgendwie klappt es
ja nun doch nicht sondern mir geht's
vielmehr um die Tatsache zu sagen war da
nicht was bei der Frage Umgang hier im
Parlament die Grünen ich finde dass sie
mit dem Begriff Reförmchen vom Kollegen
Schnieder noch extrem gut bedient sind
ich sehe noch mal diesen Ansatz in dem
was wir heute dazu diskutieren haben
aber es wollte mal gerade die Grünen
wollten den Ort dieses Parlament wieder
zur feurigen Debatte nutzen zur offenen
was nicht der Respekt der von der SPD
heran Gehalt ist als es um die Frage
ging ja schon beim Thema Geschäfts
Schluss knapp fünf vor zwölf kommt man
mal aus den pushen und überzeugt auch
oder versucht zumindest die Opposition
zu sagen man muss sie doch an die
Geschäftsordnung herangehen Herrschaften
das was im Augenblick passiert ist
wirklich schwierig der Umgang mit dem
Geschäftsgang in diesem Haus heute Nacht
kurz nach 12 400 Seiten zum Thema
energiepreisbremsen die ganze Zeit ist
man ergibt sich darin möglichst Fristen
zu reisen und dieser ständig beschworene
Konsens dann komme ich nicht fünf vor
zwölf und versuche noch dafür die
Voraussetzungen herauszubringen sondern
es Entscheidende ist wirklich Anhörungen
die nicht durchgeführt werden die
verschlepptern die verzögert werden das
alles ist respekt das alles ist
eigentlich das worum es geht ja haben
wir den Angst vor dem Sachverstand in
den Ausschusssitzungen und das bleibt
einer zukünftigen Reform schon noch mal
vorweggenommen zu sagen ist es wirklich
familienfreundlich wenn man jetzt
anfängt die Sachverständigen Anhörungen
in die nicht Sitzungswochen zu ziehen
ich würde bitten dass man sich an der
Stelle noch einmal ganz kurz damit
beschäftigt und vielleicht zur
Information was ich habe schon so weit
getrunken ist aber
diese unglaubliche Revolution beim Thema
regierungsbefragung
was natürlich der Kern dieser Änderung
ausschließlich darauf abzielt dass man
möglichst weit vorausplant damit auch
keiner mehr auf dieser Regierungsbank in
irgendeiner Art und Weise zu aktuellen
vielleicht unangenehmen Themen wird
Stellung nehmen das kann man verstanden
aber dass diese eigene Regierung ich
habe viel Verständnis für den inputus
für den Antrieb die eigene Regierung zu
schützen und zu stützen aber man muss es
auch nicht übertreiben und an dieser
Stelle zu sagen hat man wirklich Angst
von der Aktualität jetzt lässt die
Regierung hören na ja so toll finden Sie
die Pläne auch noch nicht die nächste
regierungsbefragung wird auf jeden Fall
noch dort im alten Recht durchgeführt da
bin ich ja froh dass wir eine solche
sorgsame Regierung haben bei ihrer
Koalition wie sehr folgt ich hoffe dass
bei den großen Reformen die da noch im
Raum stehen die Sie uns Antrag alle
entnehmen können wir haben da kein
Problem kein Copyright drauf schreiben
Sie es einfach ab das entschlanken der
Tagesordnung hier das Fokussieren auf
die Themen die die Gesellschaft wirklich
bewegt die Petitionen die Frage der
Vorlagen des Bundesrates nur um das
einmal kurz abzuhaken es geht schon
darum dass das was heute besprochen wird
allenfalls noch als Schützenhilfe
durchgeht aber noch nicht mal als
Reförmchen vielen Dank
Michael Frieser ist der Justitia der
Unionsfraktion und mir fällt spontan ein
wie viele Jahre die Unionsfraktion ist
abgelehnt hat dass die Bundeskanzlerin
die frühere in der regierungsbefragung
auftreten sollte es ist dann
durchgesetzt worden in der letzten
Wahlperiode und sie hat es mit Fassung
getragen und sich und häufig dabei auch
noch gepunktet jetzt wird hier eine
ganze Reihe von Anträgen abgestimmt und
dann schauen wir jetzt erstmal in
welcher Reihenfolge gewonnen mag was die
Bundestags viel zu Präsidentin hier die
verschiedenen Anträge aufruft für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
dass die Ampelkoalition wer stimmt
dagegen
cocsu und AFD wer enthält sich Fraktion
Die Linke die Beschlussempfehlung ist
damit angenommen
weiterhin empfiehlt der Ausschuss unter
Buchstabe b seiner Beschlussempfehlung
die Ablehnung des Antrags der Fraktion
der cdu/csu auf Drucksache 45 87 mit dem
Titel die Demokratie stärken klare
Reformen für ein modernes und bürgernas
Parlament wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
dass er angekoalition und die Linke wer
stimmt dagegen
das ist cdu/c so wer enthält sich der
afd-fraktion die Beschlussempfehlung ist
damit angenommen unter Buchstabe c
empfiehlt der Ausschuss die Ablehnung
des Antrags der Fraktion der AFD auf
Drucksache 45/68 mit dem Titeländerung
der Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages hier die Vermeidung von
Überschneidungen von Sitzungen des
Bundestages mit Sitzungen der Ausschüsse
und Gremien wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung das ist die
Ampelkoalition cdu/cs und die Linke wer
stimmt dagegen der afd-fraktion
Enthaltung keine Beschlussempfehlung ist
damit angenommen unter Buchstabe d
empfiehlt der Ausschuss die Ablehnung
des Antrags der Fraktion Die Linke auf
Drucksache 286 mit dem Titel Änderung
der Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages hier Ausschuss
Öffentlichkeit und Zugang von Dokumenten
wer stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
das Ampelkoalition CDU Tees und AFD wer
stimmt dagegen das ist DIE LINKE
Enthaltung gibt es keine die
Beschlussempfehlung ist damit angekommen
und des Weiteren empfiehlt der Ausschuss
unter Buchstaben E seiner
Beschlussempfehlung die Ablehnung des
Antrags der Fraktion Die Linke auf
Drucksache 17/28 mit dem Titel Änderung
der Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages hier Frist für die
Durchführung von öffentlichen Anhörungen
wer stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
die Ampelkoalition und cdu/csu wer
stimmt dagegen
afd-fraktion und die Linke Enthaltungen
keine dann ist die Beschlussempfehlung
damit angenommen und wir kommen zum
Buchstaben F der empfiehlt der Ausschuss
auch die Ablehnung des Antrages der
Fraktion Die Linke auf Drucksache 17 32
mit dem Titel Änderung der
Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages hier bessere Lesbarkeit von
Vorlagen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
ist die Ampelkoalition cdu/csu wer
stimmt dagegen die linke und die AFD
Enthaltungen gibt es keine die
Beschlussempfehlung ist damit angenommen
und schließlich empfiehlt der Ausschuss
unter dem Buchstaben G seiner
Beschlussempfehlung die Ablehnung des
Antrags der Fraktion Die Linke auf
Drucksache 1735 mit dem Titel Änderung
der Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages hier beratungsfrist wer
stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
Ampelkoalition cdu/csu wer stimmt
dagegen die linke und die AFD
Enthaltungen keine dann ist die
Beschlussempfehlung damit angenommen und
wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den
Antrag der Fraktion der AFD auf
Drucksache 48 98 mit dem Titel Änderung
der Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages hier Lesbarkeit bessere
Lesbarkeit von Drucksachen durch
Verzicht auf Gender Sprache wer stimmt
für diesen Antrag
ist die afd-fraktion wer stimmt in der
Gegend cdu/csu die Ampelkoalition und
die Linke Enthaltungen gibt es keine
dann ist der Antrag damit abgelehnt und
wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den
Antrag der Fraktion der AFD auf
Drucksache 48-97 mit dem Titel Änderung
der Geschäftsordnung des Deutschen
Bundestages hier Sachverständige vor
Hass schützen wer stimmt für diesen
Antrag die afd-fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen ist das Rest des Hauses
Enthaltungen gibt es keine der Antrag
ist damit abgelehnt